the wintry weather is a big hurdle for
the estimated six million Americans
expected to travel by plane over the
next 10 days since Friday morning more
than 5500 flights have been delayed
nationwide and more than 240 canceled
Roxana Saberi is at Newark Liberty
Airport in New Jersey which so far has
been spared any major problems Roxana
good morning good morning over the next
several days this Airport will be one of
the busiest in the country but so far
this morning people here tell us they're
in a pretty good mood
that's because lines like the one behind
me are moving smoothly triple-a expects
nearly six and a half million Americans
to fly between now and New Year's Day
many more will be hitting the road the
holiday rush has begun across the
country I think it's gone as good as it
can go the record number of Americans
expected to travel overall travelers
increase about three percent compared to
last year while the holiday travel
period is just getting underway
some people have already had their fill
my flight left Milwaukee was at by 30
departure I thought Oh it'll be really
easy but it was not so I'm hoping to
avoid the chaos but I think it's just
beginning early Friday morning fire
alarms forced travelers to evacuate
Dallas Love Field Airport affecting
hundreds of flights everybody put
anybody at LAX cars all toward the
terminal from the morning rush into the
afternoon we were prepared we woke up
early made sure we get through the
traffic
winter weather across the Northeast will
pose a continuous threat to travelers
throughout the weekend about 70% of the
United States is subject to ice and snow
so you need to be aware of that before
you hit the roads low down weather
conditions are already starting to show
like on these frost covered cars filling
Denver airport's parking lot but despite
icy road
long lines and crowded airports millions
remain determined to get home for the
holidays and triple-a says if you're
flying you should arrive at the airport
at least two hours ahead of time for
domestic flights if you're driving the
agency suggest you leave early in the
morning to avoid heavy traffic the best
days to drive Dana or on the holidays
themselves Roxana Saberi at Newark
Liberty Airport Thank You Roxana glad
I'm not in that line behind you